Hello. This is 6 Minute English
from BBC Learning English. I’m Sam.
And I’m Neil. When Helen Russell
was three years old, her new-born
baby sister died suddenly. Looking
back at that sad time, Helen remembers
making a big decision – she wanted
to be happy. She became a bestselling
author and wrote a book called, The
Atlas of Happiness. She got married,
and even moved to the famously
happy city of Copenhagen in Denmark.
But the sadness Helen felt didn’t
disappear, and the longer she lived abroad,
the more she wondered whether her
feelings were somehow connected to
being born in England, into a culture
where, traditionally, expressing your
emotions was discouraged.
In this programme, we’ll be
investigating how the way people express
sadness is influenced by their
culture, and, as usual, we’ll be
learning some new, useful vocabulary as well.
But first I have a question for
you, Neil. In English there are
many idioms which describe being
sad, including down in the dumps,
meaning that you feel miserable
and depressed. Also, emotions are
often associated with colours, for
example you might go red with anger,
or turn green with envy. But which
colour is associated with sadness? Is it:
a) yellow? b) blue? or, c) brown?
I think the answer is blue.
OK, Neil. We’ll find out
the later in the programme.
Around the world, cultures
express emotions very differently.
In Spain, flamenco performers
express their emotions with
colourful displays of song and dance,
whereas in Japan, crying is considered
weak and shameful. To discover more
about how British people express their
feelings, Helen Russell interviewed,
Thomas Dixon, a professor at the Centre
for the History of Emotion, for BBC
World Service programme, The Documentary:
The word sad, as you will know, Helen,
literally means sated or full. So,
its earliest use is in English, it means
being literally fed up, being full of
something sad or sated means heavy
and full. And then of course we
have this huge vocabulary of melancholy,
sorrow, grief, depression and
many, many other terms, and they
all mean slightly different things.
Professor Dixon explains that the
original meaning of the word sad was
‘full’ or fed up – a phrase which
today means being unhappy, bored or
tired of something which has been
going on a long time. For example:
everyone is fed up of Covid.
But fed up is just one of many words
to describe feelings of sadness,
each with a slightly different meaning.
One of them is melancholy, a kind
of intense and thoughtful sadness.
Another is grief - a strong sadness often
caused by the death of someone you love.
In Irish culture, melancholy is
expressed artistically in poems or songs.
And in other cultures, India for example,
grief can be expressed by professional
mourners who are paid to cry by the
family of the person who has died.
In England, however, big public
displays of emotion are uncommon.
But according to Professor Dixon
that wasn’t always the case. Here he
explains to BBC World Service programme,
The Documentary, how it was only
quite recently, during the time of Queen
Victoria and the British Empire, that
the English got a reputation for being repressed
- unable to show their true feelings and emotions.
By and large it's a Victorian, and then
Edwardian, and 20th century characterization.
As you can imagine, it fits with the era
of empire, of white British men going
around the world conquering it, and having
a stiff upper lip and ruling over the
people… in other parts of the world, and
believing themselves, the white Europeans,
to be superior… and one sign of
that superiority, and Darwin writes:
Englishmen rarely caught cry except
under the pressure of the acutest grief.
Professor Dixon says the Victorians who
ran the empire had a stiff upper lip.
These men believed they were better than
everyone else, and that to cry was a sign of
weakness. When we cry, our top lip starts
to wobble and so this gave rise to the
idiom a stiff upper lip, meaning to not
show your feelings when you are upset,
even though it is difficult not to.
Fortunately, most Brits are less repressed
nowadays, but it’s still hard for
some people, especially men, to express
their feelings. Sometimes drinking
alcohol gives people the courage to say
what they are feeling, but this is not
so healthy and can even
increase feelings of depression.
It’s talking to someone about your
feelings that can really help, and keep
away the blues… and in saying that I
think I’ve answered your question, Sam.
I asked Neil which colour is
often associated with feeling sad.
And I said it was blue…
Which was… the correct answer, and it
gives us another idiom about sadness –
feeling blue. OK, let’s recap the
vocabulary we’ve learned from this programme
about the emotion of sadness, or in
other words, feeling down in the dumps.
If you are fed up of something, you’re
unhappy, bored, or tired of it, especially
if it’s been happening a long time.
Melancholy is a type of intense and
thoughtful sadness; and grief is a strong
sadness usually caused by someone’s death
The adjective repressed means unable to
show your true feelings and emotions.
And finally, the uniquely British idiom,
to keep a stiff upper lip, means not to
show your feelings when you’re upset,
even though it is difficult not to.
Hiding you feelings definitely won’t make you happy,
but making friends and learning something
new might, so remember to join us
again soon, here at 6 Minute English. Bye for now!
Bye!